foreign
I did not ever want to make a video like
this
generally when I talk about queer issues
on this channel even when I directly
confront the underlying politics I do it
through the lens of geeky Media or at
the very least I somehow tie it into
things that I've addressed in the past
that are in that vein
that is not going to be the case here
no geeky tie-in no angle just the
straightforward situation
depending on who you interact with in
your life or online you may have already
heard the term transgenocide but it
could just as easily be a new term to
you
it's one that's seeing an increased use
amongst trans people and their allies
for what is currently being done by
government entities to the trans
community at Large
and there's a very good chance that the
phrase strikes you as
hyperbolic I mean trans people aren't
being herded into camps they aren't
being exterminated by the government you
may also find yourself asking doesn't
using a word like genocide to refer to a
few pieces of legislation a few States
kind of dilute the power of that word
it's also possible you're wary of the
term because the last time a term with
genocide in it started to see any kind
of wide use in this country it was a few
years back with white genocide a bunk
conspiracy narrative that postulated
non-whites were going to breed white
people out of existence or at the very
least out of being the demographic
majority in the U.S and similar Nations
it was rooted in classic white
nationalist rhetoric and yes that
instance absolutely did dilute the
meaning of the word genocide but
I also kind of suspect that that's part
of why the concept didn't really fully
latch on in the mainstream and has since
had to be rebranded as the great
replacement
for these and possibly other reasons you
may have been tilting your head or
giving a little bit of side eye to the
term transgenocide the intended audience
for this video are people who have no
open hostility towards the trans
Community but who may think that trans
activists are kind of going overboard
well with how they talk about just a
couple of laws in a few places
this video is not addressed to anyone
who already believes that trans people
are actually dangerous are a threat to
women by their presence are inherently
predatory or are looking to convert
miners I frankly don't know how to
address those people nor is it really
safe for me to attempt to do so
if you already consider yourself an ally
or you yourself are trans you may also
find this video helpful in terms of
using the information that is within it
to help you better articulate to others
what it is that has been going on
and while I could try and take a more
complete view of the scope of things and
talk about what's going on in places
such as
Uganda where the parliament there passed
a bill that criminalizes identifying as
literally anything other than
heterosexual and cisgender
which did in fact happen while I was
working on the script for this video
but I know that ultimately most of my
audience is in the US
and it's a common instinct to see what's
happening in other countries and to
assume that won't happen here
so I will be limiting my talking points
and specific examples and citations to
things that have taken place within the
United States moreover nearly every
example that I'm going to cite are going
to be ones that have come about in the
year 2023
this is not to minimize the horrible
things occurring around the world or to
ignore what has happened in years prior
but simply to Grant this specific video
a narrower Focus for the sake of clarity
with the intended audience
I'm going to do my best to talk simply
and plainly
I do not intend to raise my voice I hope
to avoid hypotheticals and what-if
scenarios
I'm not going to get into the recently
gained insight about who is forming
these laws and how they have been going
about it and I do not intend to single
out any specific individuals by name be
they politicians public figures or other
creators
it is my hope to deal with very simple
facts that should not be in dispute
and with all that established the
question I hope to address is this does
what is happening to trans people across
the U.S constitute the use of the word
genocide
now firstly we're going to have to
actually Define genocide because to look
at how the term is used and reacted to
in the US we appear to actually have a
bit of a skewed idea of what actually
constitutes a genocide this is likely
owing to the fact that most Americans
are only really ever taught about one
genocide in their time at school and
that being naturally the Holocaust
American students are rarely if ever
taught about the genocides that took
place between World War II and the
present in places such as Myanmar Darfur
the Democratic Republic of Congo India
Cambodia Algeria and many others
American schools May teach a limited
amount about the native and Indigenous
people displaced by colonialization and
expansion of the United States but it
will virtually never be identified as
what it was which was genocide
and what Americans think about genocide
they think Nazis they think
concentration camps they think showers
where people were gassed to death on
mass and while the Holocaust was a
genocide it was not the only form that
genocide can take
this is extremely important to
understand because otherwise it Narrows
the view of what genocide even is and if
you're worried I might be trying to
redefine the term to include more things
allow me to provide you the five acts
that constitute genocide against a group
as adopted by the UN General Assembly in
1948.
one killing members of the group
two causing serious bodily or mental
harm to members of the group three
deliberately inflicting on the group
conditions of Life calculated to bring
about its physical destruction in whole
or in part
four imposing measures intended to
prevent births within the group
five forcibly transferring Children of
the group to another group
we're going to go over these points and
look at them through the lens of What
legislation has either already been
passed or been proposed within the
United States
however I am going to make some
concessions and some clarifications
as currently defined by the UN and
international criminal courts genocide
is taken against National ethnic racial
or religious groups for the purposes of
potential prosecution by the
international criminal courts groups
such as sex gender or sexual orientation
aren't currently included but that's
only the strictest legal definition and
there have been attempts to amend this
I'm acknowledging this because if I
don't I know I'll be accused of
manipulating facts by Omission however
I'm going to suggest to you that a group
of people being subjected to any of
those five activities for things they
cannot change about themselves such as
being gay or transgender or intersex
should be viewed as that group being the
target of genocide as a practical matter
even if it is not considered to be that
as a matter of law
if you're not willing to go that far
then at least I hope you'll accept that
the qualifier of trans in the term
transgenocide is making clear what group
these actions are being taken against
and makes it a potentially accurate
descriptor if these five actions can be
demonstrated as being taken against
trans people
so
can they be demonstrated
well
let's go through the points I listed
first there is the most obvious Act
killing members of the group again this
is what most Americans will think of
when they think genocide and at present
while there is a great deal of violent
rhetoric these days in this country at
least there is no proposed legislation
which would impose the threat of death
upon trans people for being trans
we could get into how the legislation
that is in play promotes and empowers
general hostility and creates a climate
that encourages more and more people to
take violent action against people who
are trans and the statistics bear out
that this is already occurring but since
it's not actually being proposed
legislatively for the sake of clarity
and to avoid muddying the waters we will
set the Act of Killing members of the
group aside
the other one we can set aside at this
time is imposing measures intended to
prevent births within the group there
are at present no proposals that I'm
aware of that push for the sterilization
of trans people
and there likely won't be due to a
somewhat unique Quirk of the situation
while trans men and non-binary people
with uteruses are by no means safe in
the current climate the focus of
legislative measures as well as rhetoric
against trans people has focused very
heavily on trans women
the most common Medical Aid to
transition from a masculine to a
feminine state for trans women is
through hormone replacement therapy or
HRT and it often takes less than a year
on HRT for a person assigned male at
Birth to be rendered infertile now trans
men and non-binary people with uteruses
are still quite capable of bearing
children but again they are rarely
singled out and thus far haven't been in
these proposed laws so far as I am aware
as with the Act of Killing group members
there are things that could muddy these
Waters such as restricting the ability
of trans people to adopt or attempts to
deny trans people the right to marry and
of course the crossover with the current
attack on Reproductive Rights in general
in this country but
as before we shall set this one aside
that leaves us with three remaining acts
that constitute genocide
and before I start addressing those I
want to point out and make clear
something that is very
very important to understand
to meet the criteria of genocide it does
not require that all these acts be
committed against a group it requires
that only one
be committed it's not a checklist you
don't have to do them all also I'll
remind you that the acts need not be
taken against the entirety of the group
but merely against members of the group
for the strict reason that they are
members of that group so the fact that
much of what I'm going to be talking
about is specifically targeting only
portions of the trans Community often
trans Youth and is doing so in only a
limited number of states at this time
an applicable act would still qualify as
an act of genocide against the group as
a whole from here out I'm going to start
citing specific laws either proposed or
passed
I will not be able to be anything close
to comprehensive about this both because
there is an ongoing flood of these and
any attempt at a complete list would be
out of date as soon as it was uploaded
and also because there's been nearly 400
bills targeting lgbtqia plus people in
general or trans people in specific
since the start of 2023.
I will cite specific bills and the
states in which they have been proposed
or enacted and you can certainly look
them up for yourself to be sure that I
have not distorted them
but understand that for as many specific
ones as I give there will be dozens if
not hundreds of comparable proposed
bills in other states
it's possible that some of these will
not pass
or may even have been defeated by the
time this video is live to the public
but the very fact that they were
proposed and debated in state
legislatures makes them relevant to the
discussion regardless because it is
illustrative of the intent of those
pushing these bills and the current
climate in which they are being put
forward
so
let us get back to our remaining three
acts of genocide and address causing
serious bodily or mental harm to members
of the group
two relevant laws to bring up around an
act such as this would include Georgia
Senate Bill 140 and South Dakota House
Bill
1080. both of which ban gender affirming
medical treatment for Trans youth
it's worth noting that these bills do
not ban any specific treatment or
medication in and of itself rather they
banned their use strictly for the
purposes of gender affirmation
so if say a minor is diagnosed with
Central precocious puberty they may be
prescribed leoprolide acetate it's a
slow development but a minor cannot be
prescribed the same medication to delay
or prevent the onset of a puberty they
do not desire because it would force
them into an identity they don't have no
matter the wishes of those children
their parents or the advice of any
medical professionals treating them they
will not be prescribed those medications
for that purpose
this creates a situation where trans
youth who know that they are trans and
know that they are not the gender they
were assigned at Birth will be given no
option but to undergo a puberty into a
body they do not want do not identify
with and will cause potentially severe
dysphoria resulting in both mental
distress and physical traumatic changes
the ramifications of which
will be that those youths will try and
undo that with HRT once they are legally
adults at least in some states because
there are laws like Oklahoma Senate Bill
129 which renders illegal any gender
affirming care for Trans individuals
until they are 26 years of age
this strips not only minors but legal
adults of the rights to seek medical
assistance in affirming their gender
identity and would cause any adult under
26 currently on a hormone regimen in
that state to be denied those treatments
until they quote unquote come of age
resulting in potentially traumatizing
forced detransition
forcing trans people to remain in or
return to a life a body and a hormone
balance that causes them physical
emotional and mental distress fits very
cleanly
into causing serious bodily harm or
mental harm to members of the group
now next we have deliberately inflicting
on the group conditions of Life
calculated to bring about its physical
destruction in whole or in part
this one admittedly is going to be
slightly more interpretive on my part
than the last one due to the inclusion
of intent in its wording and intent is
something which can be disputed unless I
go down the rabbit hole of these
specific people bringing these laws
forward and I said I was not going to do
that
but I feel that enough of these laws at
least brush up against this act that it
warrants discussion even if it's the
least clear-cut instance that I will be
addressing going forward
this is where we can bring up Tennessee
Senate Bill 3. otherwise known as the
anti-drag bill officially the bill
classifies male or female impersonators
as adult Cabaret entertainers grouping
them in with strippers and exotic
dancers and bans them from performing in
any space where a miner might see them
in other words any public space
this practically function as a ban on
Pride celebrations but it's the
vagueness of the wording
that enables it to be wielded against
trans people even though they are not
specifically cited the bill does not
define male or female impersonator and
since Tennessee does not allow for the
changing of gender markers on birth
certificates it will be possible for a
legal argument to be made that any trans
person is in fact a male or female
impersonator since the state does not
fully recognize that they are no longer
the gender that they were assigned at
Birth
the bill also fails to Define what a
performance is
leaving any individuals enforcing the
law to decide if someone they believe to
be a male or female impersonator is
giving a performance
the Practical upshot of the bill creates
a legally fragile situation for any
trans person to simply be out in public
in the state of Tennessee the vagueness
creates so much uncertainty for Trans
people that the safest option
is for them to flee the state
not leave their homes
or detransition in part or in full
conditions of Life have been altered to
suppressed restrict and terrify trans
people into invisibility and compliance
and while I can't speak to the specific
intent of those who brought forth and
passed this law I feel at the very least
it warrants consideration of matching
the act of inflicting conditions of Life
calculated to bring about the
destruction of the group in whole
or in part
finally there is forcibly transferring
Children of the group to another group
and this one we are back to extremely
straightforward examples
earlier this year in Florida Senate Bill
254 was introduced
in its current form this law would
classify any gender affirming care
granted to a minor as
unjustifiable conduct and serious
physical harm it grants jurisdiction of
the child to the state which would
Empower State agents to remove a trans
minor from their home and family it
would also attempt to use serp parental
rights in other states laying out
specifically that the court should not
treat as criminal the removal of a child
from one parent by the other parent even
if it involves bringing a child across
state lines if the removal was done to
prevent gender affirming care the
Practical upshot of this would mean that
if a couple is divorced or unwed and one
parent has full custody of their child
and that child is trans the parent with
no custody rights will be protected if
they kidnap the trans child and claim
they did so to protect them from trans
affirming care the law specifically lays
out that this would be the case even if
the parent with custody resides outside
the State of Florida and it does not
even require that transaffirming care be
currently being provided it is only
necessary that there is a belief that a
youth is at risk of receiving gender
affirming care
and that is true of the entire Bill
there need only be a suspicion that a
child is at risk of being supported and
receiving affirming care for the state
to either remove that child themselves
or look the other way as a non-custodial
parent does it and while the bill is
targeted at trans youth the broadness of
at-risk could also put transgender
parents under legal scrutiny as well as
it would be very straightforward to
argue that if a parent is trans they
would be transaffirming to their
children if those children
ever took on a trans identity and thus
those children are at risk
to show that this is not a one-off
proposal or some kind of fluke unique to
Florida I am going to briefly step
outside of legislation as well as the
current year to touch instead
on the directives of Governors
while a governor cannot pass laws on
their own they can direct the priorities
and adjust the guidelines of many state
agencies
and in 2022 as a Governor's directive
the Texas department of family
Protective Services was instructed to
consider parents and families supportive
of trans youth to be engaging in child
abuse and to investigate them on that
basis and while this is currently being
fought in court the natural outcome of
such an investigation when simply being
supportive of a miners transition alone
is considered abuse is to remove that
minor from their family and force them
into the foster care system
these are laws and directives that
simply and plainly attempt to remove
trans youth from affirming and
supportive parents and in some
interpretations opens the door to even
cisgender children being removed from
the homes of transparents
children would be forcibly removed from
the group and transferred to another
group
and I'd like to add an additional
thought here in case anyone is thinking
to themselves well many of these trans
kids don't live with transparent so are
they really being taken away from that
group I would argue that in the case of
being transgender that the parents not
being trans themselves does not matter
and that them being trans affirming
essentially makes it all the same
function the reason in the case of a
national or religious group to remove
the children from the homes and take
them away from those group and put them
in another group is to ensure that they
do not be raised in that state and with
those people and affirming those beliefs
nationalities Etc removing trans
children from affirming parents serves
the exact same purpose even if those
parents themselves are not trans
so there we have it
three
criteria that are either already being
met or being approached by proposed or
already enacted legislation so to answer
the core question in all of this is what
is happening in the U.S to trans people
a form of genocide
yes
these laws and directives and many that
I haven't even spoken about both
individually and collectively are an
attempt to commit genocide against trans
people
I deeply hope that I have demonstrated
that
and there are some states attempting
to go in the other direction such as
Minnesota with the proposed bill hf-146
which would make the state a refuge for
those fleeing prosecution for being
Trans in other states in Canada while it
is in fact already permitted for people
to seek Asylum to flee persecution on
the basis of gender identity or
sexuality there is a Groundswell of
support for a petition to strengthen and
fully codify those guidelines in the
face of what is happening in the U.S
but understand that these actions do not
balance out
while some areas strengthening
protections is certainly welcome so many
have already enacted appalling
restrictions on existing as a trans
person
and leading Republican candidate for
president Donald Trump who is the only
person I'm going to mention by name has
already stated his intention to strip
support for transgender people as part
of his official election platform right
now it is localized to certain States
but it can become a national crisis on
the results of a single election
but truly the fact that it could get
worse shouldn't be necessary to point
out because it's already gone farther
than it ever should have been allowed
there are lots of points I could make I
could bring up
that other groups
that these same tactics could be used
against such as cisgender gays and
lesbians
are going to be at risk soon if they're
not already I could point out the
parallels between what we've already
seen happen in other genocides around
the world historical and current I could
bring up the fact that an invited
speaker at one of the most influential
conservative events in the country
called for the quote eradication of
transgenderism and that statement was
met with Applause
but I shouldn't have to because we're
already in an active genocide attempt
right now not in the future not down the
line write this instant and if the
government doesn't round up and
exterminate trans people know that trans
people are dying because of these
actions anyway
their quality of life is dropping they
are being excluded from public life and
people who hate us feel empowered to
assault and kill us because everything
about this tells them that we are less
than human and they do not have to think
of us as deserving of anything not even
our own lives
at the end of 2022 the Human Rights
Campaign noted an epidemic of violence
against trans people
last year
34 trans people were killed not died
were killed and this year so far there
have been six that we know of
and those may not seem like big numbers
to you
but I want you to hear their names
because they weren't statistics
they were people
they were Amaria lay
Duvall princess
Cyprus Ramos
Naomi Skinner
Matthew Angelo spampinato
Paloma Vasquez
Tatiana LaBelle
Catherine Katie Newhouse
Kenyatta kesho Webster
Mia Love Parker
Ariana Mitchell
Fern feather
Ray Muscat
Nedra sequence Morris
shanalika Ela Dior Hemingway
Sasha Mason
Brazil Johnson
Giselle Marie
Kitty Monroe
martasia Richmond
Keshia Chanel getter
Cherry bush
Maricela Castro
Hayden Davis
candy red
Aaron Lynch
Maddie Hoffman
Dede Rex
Maya Allen
AC Morrison
samaj Billingsley
Tiffany Banks
Daniel Ashton
Kelly loving
tortugita
cheshay Henderson
Maria Jose Rivera Rivera
unique Banks
Casey Johnson
Jasmine star Mack
these names don't even begin to address
the issue of suicide
a growing concern for many trans people
especially trans youth as the future
they saw for themselves is ripped away
from them and the only future they can
see is one in which they are forced to
live a life that brings them pain
because it's simply not who they are
and when faced with that future some
will opt out
by whatever means they feel are
necessary
we have already seen this play out this
year
with Eden Knight
a trans college student
isolated by American fixers
who returned her to Saudi Arabia where
she was forcibly detransitioned and
chose to end her own life
what we are seeing happen in the United
States will only result in more deaths
and the people proposing and passing
these laws know this
they have been told they have been told
by community members parents medical
professionals trans youth themselves
they are not ignorant of the deaths that
will occur and yet they moved forward
because they see the lives of trans
people as an acceptable price to pay and
that is me being generous because the
alternative is that these deaths are
actually the desired outcome
if you live in a state where these laws
have been proposed please call your
congressperson please make your voice
heard please contact local lgbtqia plus
supportive groups and find out what they
need
in order to do the most good in your
area
if you live in an area currently
considered safe
as I do
then please consider donating or
supporting in any way you can any of the
following organizations
the Trevor Project
trans lifeline
Human Rights Campaign Foundation
and the national Center
for Trans equality
there are other organizations as well I
encourage you to seek out other
recommendations but these are places to
start
it feels gross to do my usual
self-promotion at the end of this you
can look down in the description of this
video if you are interested in any of my
other works or ways to support me
as I said at the start I didn't want to
make this
ever
I want to talk about geeky nonsense
and get hyped for Doctor Who
I don't want to be an advocate I truly
do not
but in a situation like this
what I want
is the wrong perspective
this is what I can do
and I need to do it
if you've gotten to the end of this
video
then it will say to you now
as I always have
that no matter what else
is going on
in this country or the world right now I
need you to remember
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
please
take care out there of yourself and of
those around you be well
be safe
and be kind